(upbeat ethereal music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large brain,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understand of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(upbeat staccato music)
(upbeat techno music)
- So, before I start, let me
explain the general approach
that I'm taking to the theme
of this symposium today.
As an anthropologist, my first
port of call for addressing
any question about human
beings has to be the place
where I've done field work.
This is because while all
human beings are confronted
by the same fundamental
questions, and approach them
through the same fundamental
capacities that are afforded
by their minds and bodies,
they always bring to the task
of framing the questions
and finding the answers,
tools that are specific to
the historical and cultural
context in which they live and die.
And to talk sensibly
about the human beings,
their questions and answers,
one has to know this context well.
So, let me take you to Betania,
a small fishing village
on the west coast of Madagascar.
The inhabitants are fishing
folk who describe themselves
as Vezo, people of the sea.
This is where I've done
field work, on and off,
for the past 30 years.
During this time, I've
seen babies being born,
children grow into adults,
adults age into wise elders,
and lots of people of all
ages die and been buried
in the village cemetery.
In Betania, when someone
dies, the whole village
springs into action.
Depending on the age and
the status of the deceased,
the funeral proceedings last
between one and four days.
Each day villagers are expected
to attend two communal meals
and a vigil.
As you can imagine, organizing
such events is a huge
undertaking for the bereaved family.
And while a few individuals
are in charge of preparing
the corpse and of dealing
with the deceased's closest
and most distressed relatives,
the vast majority of
family members will be busy
dealing with other things.
Their first task is to
formally announce the death
to everyone who has a right to be told.
A young boy is sent to all
the households in the village,
older youths are dispatched
to more distant locations.
A text is delivered to the radio station
in the nearest town, a text
which announces who has died
and lists all the names of
all the people the death
is being announced to.
Meanwhile, money is urgently
collected from family members.
The money is needed to buy
the vast quantities of rice
and meat for the communal
meals and the rum and coffee
for the vigils.
It is important that the
crowds are not let down,
for example, by serving them
beans or fish instead of meat,
or by running out of rum
halfway through the night.
(audience laughing)
It is shameful, mahamenatra,
to fail to pull it off.
Not only because this shows
that the most immediate family
doesn't have the necessary
resources but also,
and perhaps most importantly,
because it shows that they
don't have enough relations
willing to help them out.
In fact, everyone in
attendance is supposed to make
a monetary contribution.
As the crowds assemble, the
elders of the bereaved family
set themselves up in one of their houses.
There they receive representatives
of each of the village
households and those
visitors who have come
from further field.
After a certain amount of
highly formalized exchanges,
the visitors produce an
envelope while insisting
that it's nothing big,
just a little thing.
The envelope is accepted
by the elders who insist
that it's not small, but a big thing.
After some more back and
forth, the visitors leave,
the envelope is opened, the money counted,
and the amount carefully written
down in a special notebook.
The visitors will have
done the same at their end
consulting their notebooks
to find out how much
they had received from the
bereaved family last time they,
themselves, had a funeral.
And noting down the amounts
they're now contributing.
In this way, all the time,
people ensure that they
reciprocate the contributions
they have received, thus
maintaining good relations
and not losing face.
This kind of reciprocation
doesn't always work
but it's always closely monitored.
Such-and-such a family has
brought less than expected.
Is it because they're
really struggling or because
they are trying to slight us?
Another family has brought much more.
Are they just being generous
or are they testing us
to see whether we can match
their contribution in the future?
Now the reason I'm mentioning all of this,
the announcing, the collecting,
the giving, the receiving,
the writing down is that
these are the activities
that dominate the funeral.
Of course, funerals wouldn't
happen if there was no death.
But the point I wish to stress
is that for the vast majority
of people, the deceased is
actually quite peripheral
to their experience and preoccupations.
The same applies to their
emotional experience.
Of course they are close
family members who are highly
distressed and grief stricken,
but for most participants
funerals elicit a variety
of emotions ranging from
plain boredom to
alcohol-induced exhilaration,
to sexual arousal.
This last one applies
especially to youths who find
in funerals the welcome
opportunity to meet visitors
from distant villages who, with any luck,
are not genealogically
related to them and are thus
permissible sexual partners.
Indeed, it's well known that
many long-lasting marriages
started at the edges of a vigil.
(audience laughing)
Now, to put all this into
context, consider that
say for the crowds that
gather for the much rarer
construction of tombs, events
which are planned in advance
and are announced, and therefore
have a better attendance,
funerals are the largest
gatherings of people
that villagers participate in.
And they're events which give
them a firsthand experience
of the large scale social
system to which they belong.
Here are these hundreds of other people,
and he were are, my parents,
my children, my siblings,
my in-laws, just one note of
this vast network of relations.
And while funerals give people
a snapshot of the existing
social landscape, they're also
occasions for acting on it
and changing its shape.
For example, by extending or
withdrawing the announcement
of the death, by succeeding
or failing to put on
a good funeral, by giving a
small or a large or a balanced
contribution, and most
literally, by having sex,
which has the potential of
adding new life to the mix.
You will have noticed that
quite deliberately I've led you
away from the deceased
and the raw emotions
that surround death.
I've done so to dispel
the commonsense assumption
that funerals are essentially
about death and grief
and to stress the point that
they are instead largely about
the gathering of crowds, the
expectations and obligations
that people have, the
appraisal and manipulation
of the social relations
in which they live.
Still, there is a dead body
at the center of it all.
A body that is fast decomposing
and that, sooner or later,
must be removed from the
village, taken to the cemetery,
and placed inside a tomb, one
of the many large enclosures
that are scattered around the sand dunes.
Once the body is buried, an
elder gives an explanatory
speech informing the other
dead of what has just happened.
He will then state that
the deceased has arrived
at the place where he is, plasy misy azy,
but nothing more is left to
be done and that the crowd
should now disperse and go home.
The place where he or she
is is a misleadingly simple
expression which, in
fact, captures key aspects
of the existential transformation
brought about by death.
First note that this is not
an expression that is used
to refer to the journeys of living people.
Living people arrive here and
there but they don't arrive
at the place where they are.
This makes sense because living people
are always on the move.
They leave, they arrive,
and then they move on.
Dead people, by contrast,
arrive inside their tombs
and there they stay.
Second, the expression
draws attention to the fact
that the deceased arrives
at that specific place,
this tomb, not another one.
The choice of tomb is a
highly contentious affair.
This is because as people
often told me by way of
explanation, we can't cut
up corpses into pieces.
In other words, the
deceased cannot be buried
in more than one tomb.
In theory, the choice
of burial is determined
by strict rules which
say that children's bones
belong to their mother unless
the father acquires them
through ritual means.
In practice, lots of other
factors can feed into
the final decision.
But the point is that
when the decision is made,
it is final.
The overall point I want
to get across is this.
By the placing the dead in
the place where they are,
the living create a radically
different social system
to the one they experience
when they are alive.
A system that lacks movement
the dead arrive once and for all.
A system that is not open to negotiation.
The dead are either here or there.
A system of social
relations that are no longer
a work in progress.
The dead are no longer
susceptible to the vagaries
of personal success and
failures, likes and dislikes,
distance and proximity, and so on.
From this perspective, it's
not surprising that the tombs,
which create this
alternative social system,
are the most solid and lasting
structures that people build.
They used to be made of
hard wood but once cement
became available in the '60s,
it soon became the
material of choice because,
as people say, it's harder,
more durable, and movable.
Given the eerie stillness of corpses,
it's also not surprising that humans,
not just in Madagascar, imagine
the transition from life
to death as one that
turns the movement of life
into immobility and that
removes the deceased
from the give and take
of human interactions
as we've just seen.
But humans, not just in
Madagascar, seem also prone
to imagine something a
little more paradoxical.
Namely that the social
systems created through death
are long lasting.
That they transcend the now on, now off,
temporality of life.
For this to happen, however,
something has to give.
To put it in the most general terms,
the complexity of life has to be reduced,
the makeup of the living
person has to be stripped down
to its core, its essence
has to be distilled
out of its many entanglements.
Only when this happens can
people begin to imagine
that the present is just
a replica of the past
and that the future will be
a replica of the present.
In other words, they can
begin to imagine a system
that defies the passage of time.
I'm getting ahead of myself
here so let me give you
a couple of examples to illustrate
where I'm actually heading.
First, to the Vezo, the living,
people say, have at least
eight ancestral lines of descent.
Those of their eight great grandparents.
In fact, they would have more
if they could remember them.
This means that in life,
each person is made up of
at least eight known ancestral
parts which are unique
to that person because only that person
and her full siblings share
that exact combination
of ancestral sources.
And so when that person dies,
that unique combination
also comes to an end.
But now imagine that
when that person dies,
she's buried inside
the tomb which contains
only individuals who share
one of her eight ancestral
lines of descent.
In being placed there, all of
these individuals had seven
of their ancestral lines stripped away,
thus being reduced to that
one that they have in common.
And so instead of being
unique combinations that are
here today and gone tomorrow,
they all become a replica
of one another, a continuation
of that one line of ancestry.
And so in and through death,
people begin to imagine
a social grouping, what Vezo
called one kind of people,
and anthropologists call
a unilineal descent group,
which has continuity through time.
Let me briefly turn to
another example to explain
why death, in particular,
is such a powerful moment
for imagining this type of continuity.
For this I draw on the
work of anthropologist,
Martha Macintyre, who has worked
on the island of Tubetube,
one of the many islands
in the Masima region
of Papua, New Guinea.
Here, as in many other
places in this region,
the social groupings
that last through time
are named matrilineages, each
made up of all the people
who can trace descent through women
to the same female forebear.
People here have a folk
theory of the human body
which says that bones are
made up of mother's milk,
which in turn is passed
from mother to daughter,
down the generations.
The bones, in other words,
are quintessentially maternal
substance which is sourced all the way up
to that founding female forebear.
This means that quite
literally the members of the
matrilineage share the exact same bones.
When it comes to bones,
they are one kind of people.
Each person, just a replica
of one another through time.
But you can see the
problem with this idea.
Living people, kicking,
screaming, crawling babies
are not made of just bones.
To be viable persons they
also need blood and flesh.
This soft and wobbly stuff,
the folk theory goes,
comes from the father.
And because one's father belongs
to a different matrilineage
from that of one's mother,
the marriage would
otherwise be incestuous,
the living person can only
ever be a mixed-up person,
an idiosyncratic combination
of these maternal bones
and those paternal blood and flesh.
A combination which, like
the eight ancestral sources
of the Vezo, is here
today and gone tomorrow.
However, death resolves the problem.
Quite literally, the process
of decomposition gets rid
of the paternal stuff, leaving
just the maternal bones.
In addition, funerals consist
of complex transactions
in which goods that represent
flesh and blood are sent
back to the family of the
father of the deceased,
which originally
contributed to the person.
In this way, funerals are
thought to de-conceive
the person who has just died.
As a result of all this,
the people of Tubetube
come to imagine the essence
of their matrilineage,
the bones in their pure
and unadulterated form
as lasting through time.
Originating in the ancestral
past and ready to be passed on
to the next generation.
This, then, is why death
is a source of celebration.
Sure, people are born to
produce, age, and die.
As individuals they are here
today and gone tomorrow.
But death lends itself,
aided by a lot of ritual
and imaginative work, to
the creation of systems
of social relations between
the dead and the living,
between the living and the unborn,
which are long lasting,
defy the passage of time,
and transcend death itself.
Let me conclude with a
reflection on the contemporary
relevance of what I've
presented you today,
drawing on material from some
very far off lands and people.
The reflection is that there
is an obvious dark side
to the celebration.
A dark side, which my Vezo friends,
I just state this without
having time to explain,
have found ways of overcoming
but others have not.
The dark side is that, as
you might have noticed,
the process of creating
long lasting social systems
based on kinds of people
that are nicely sorted
into separate tombs or based
on the recovery of pure
and pristine bones gives rise
to a kind of essentialist
thinking that can very quickly
turn into ethnic hatred,
parochial nationalism,
and racial discrimination.
So that instead of building
walls around the dead,
we find walls sprouting up
everywhere to divide people
who are believed to be
essentially like us from people
essentially different from us.
And when this happens,
the celebration is over.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat ethereal music)